The Joe Rogan Experience
um so I wanted to talk to you about this
cloning and the the rewilding of the
mammoths and yeah all that stuff I'm
going to colossal tomorrow to to learn a
little bit more about it explain
Colossal yeah so colossal biosciences is
this if you ask me incredible company
and they are by their own declaration a
de-extinction company so it's this guy
Ben lamb and he's got George Church
who's a world leading
um a cellular scientist I don't know the
specifics you know of the extinction and
cloning of crispr and so on and so forth
and they've come together and raised a
ton of money and they are de-extincting
animals and the science is there like
it's done all it took was the the money
basically behind it and they've put
together this incredible Rolodex of
scientists and people and it's it's it's
real life Jurassic Park with purpose
where are they gonna put them uh so
there's a couple different things going
on so the first one they're working on
is the woolly mammoth right and this
isn't just for fun this is this has real
like important conservation implications
which is really fascinating
um but they are going they're planning
on starting with I think a hundred
mammoths and putting them in this place
called pleistocene not pleistine Park uh
something like that at this park in
Siberia
um that they've been doing this
experiment on as to what happens when
you add megafauna back into the Arctic
tundra to offset carbon emissions wow
and so they're using what DNA they're
using elephant DNA and mixing it with
something else so it's it's Indian
elephant is the closest living relative
to the woolly mammoth what does an
Indian elephant look like is it similar
to an elephant yeah it's a smaller so
African elephants are bigger they have
the really big ears right Indian
elephants are typically the ones you'd
see at the circus you know with the red
the pink in the ears the smaller
triangular shaped ears so just a
different species of elephant
um and so they're taking Indian
elephants and they're using crisper
technology and they're using existing
Mammoth DNA and they're making an embryo
and then they're implanting it into the
Indian elephant and 22 months later an
Indian elephants gestation period She
will give birth to a mammoth
a real mammal a real Mammoth so it's not
like a hybrid
that's okay that's a good point so it is
in the sense of what they do is if you
imagine like
if you imagine the DNA of an animal
right and then you imagine the fragments
that are broken out of it right what
they're doing is they're taking that DNA
of the and I don't understand the
cellular side of it very well this is
just my base level understanding of it I
can talk about the conservation side of
it but they're taking that double helix
that DNA and all those pieces that are
missing from the mammoth they're putting
in
um Indian elephant pieces so you end up
with an animal that is
physically and morphologically identical
to a mammoth but has used all of the DNA
from the closest living relatives in
order to get there
boy and this process how long does this
take
so I think they've been going for about
five years on the science but the
science of de-extinction and cloning I
mean you remember Dolly the sheep right
that was like a known thing so that's
been going on for a long time well you
can get your cat cloned exactly dog
clone exactly for like 20 grand you can
clone your dog yeah so it's kind of
creepy it is it's bizarre
um but the point is the science has been
there for a while there just hasn't
really been the funding or the
motivation for it but what I what I
think so fascinating the reason I'm so
like emotionally invested in it is the
conservation implications that it has
because what they're this company's
ultimately doing is rewilding species
that humans have removed and that's
going to in theory in a lot of places
sort of fix the the the offset the
imbalance of the ecosystem that's
interesting that's really interesting
there's a lot of debate about whether or
not humans killed off the woolly mammoth
though isn't there I think there is yeah
I think there is and I I can't really
speak on that but I I do know that when
the mammoths disappeared so the arc
Arctic used to be like the Savannahs of
Africa it used to be big grasslands
right it wasn't all covered in trees and
things and that's a recent adaptation
since the mammoths went away 10 20 000
years ago and so that's what's happened
is the permafrost up there is melting
pretty rapidly right underneath that
permafrost is like one and a half
trillion tons of carbon and once that
carbon enters the atmosphere it Heats
things up like crazy so with by removing
those mammoths
um you're and I can explain why the
Mounds keep it colder but by removing
those mammoths it's allowing that
permafrost to melt much quicker and
release more carbon so the idea from
like a financial standpoint of how they
make money is the carbon offset of
putting mammoths back into the
environment how do they make it colder
so it's a couple different things it's
um
basically when there's trees and shrubs
they take in more heat and that heat
transfers into the ground so in this
pleistocene park this park that they've
been doing this experiment in Siberia
for a while they have they put in a
couple hundred animals that aren't
mammoths right they've put in ox and
um reindeer and things like that and
they're knocking trees over with the
tractors and once they knock trees over
and they simulate a mammoth knocking the
trees and shrubs over the other the
fleet grazers are able to keep the the
vegetation from regrowing so when the
vegetation doesn't regrow you get all
this grassland and the grassland has
snowpack the snowpack gets stumped so
there's no insulation it reflects more
light it just it's like it's like three
or four different processes that make
the ground I think on average it's like
eight degrees colder so it keeps things
more Frozen so once we removed all the
megafauna from the Arctic through
hunting or maybe other means regardless
once they were removed the Arctic got
warmer the Siberia and Alaska got warmer
and so slowly we're getting more and
more carbon emissions from up there but
by putting these animals back and I just
love the idea of going up to the Arctic
and it looking like the African Savannah
right with all these incredible animals
but um by putting these animals back it
in theory will make the Arctic colder
slow down the melting of the permafrost
which will in turn trap the carbon for
longer in the ground